If you ask British school children, what happens in the year 10 66,
they will undoubtedly answer the battle of Hastings fought on October the 14th.
They're marked the successful invasion of England's by the Duke of Normandy,
William, the conqueror. But earlier that year,
another pivotal event took place nine months earlier on January the fifth and
elderly King died in the Abbey that he had built Westminster.
His reign had been largely peaceful, stable, and prosperous,
but he passed away without,
as leaving the kingdom in a chaotic mess with four different contenders laying
claim to the throne.
This is the story of that King considered by supporters as a
fair and pious Monarch.
He was slandered by his critics as weak and ineffectual yet also prone to
violence. He went down in history as both a King and a Saint Edward,
the confessor, the last Saxon King of England.
[Inaudible].
If you know your history, you know that William,
the congruence defeated King Harold Godwinson at Hastings.
So Harold should be considered the last Saxon King, right? Well,
yes, but also know as well learned later,
the legitimacy of Harold's reign was contested from the very start.
And in any case, his Tonya on the throne lasted only 10 months.
So it may be more correct to say that Edward was the last real Saxton King of
England whose legitimacy was not disputed.
And to sat on the throne for a more reasonable amount of time.
The claim of Edward of Saxon King was upheld by none other than Winston
Churchill in his history of the English speaking people.
So Winston thus describes the final moments of Edwards.
The lights of Saxon England were going out and in the gathering darkness,
a gentle gray beard prophet for told the ends when on his
deathbed, Edward spoke of a time of evil that was coming upon.
The land is inspired.
Muttering struck terror into the is thus on January the fifth,
10 66,
and did the line of the Saxon Kings Churchill wrote this passage and he put
1940. When Britain faced these serious threats of a German invasion,
we can therefore understand if he foreshadows the Norman conquest as a time of
evil. We can also forgive this. He overlooked an important fact about Edwards.
The sea was a half Norman by birth and culturally Norman by his upbringing.
This is why we have placed a nice question Mark. In the title of this episode,
the last of the Saxon Kings question, Mark can also be read like this.
The last of the Saxon Kings.
Edward.
Was born sometime between 10 Oh two and 10 Oh five at S snip in Oxford.
His parents were Emma of Normandy and King Ethel read the second of England's
belonging to the Nobel house of West sex. As the red was Christians.
This is the unreadiness styling that is more accurately interpreted the unwise
or the one without counsel as a King of the red found it difficult to defend his
lands from frequent raids, by Danish Vikings,
a the red trying to keep the deans at Bay by lying himself with the Normans.
He cemented and Alliance by virtue of his marriage to Emma daughter of the Duke
of Normandy. This was ethelred second marriage.
He had already fathered six children from a previous wife of which the eldest
Edmond was the next in line to the throne.
Emma gave two children to the unready Edward and Alfred's an
autobiography of Edward claims that all English novels already hailed him as
their next King while he was still unborn.
The same text mentions that upon his birth, Edward was entrusted by his parents,
do the cat of a monastic order.
This text may have been hagiographic or intentionally aimed to celebrating
Edward as a Saint. Nonetheless,
it sets the tone for two important forces that drove Edward's future life.
His desire to take the throne as a legitimate heir and his deep
religious beliefs, early childhood,
his father struggled to keep England free of Danish. Yeah.
He results to paying what we could define as protection, money to the Danes.
This was ultimately money that HealthRIGHT extracted from his subjects via a
heavy tax known as the Dane gals, the Vikings pocketed the money,
of course, but according to the Anglo Saxon Chronicle,
they went about as they pleased. In other words,
the bribe money hadn't really altered their behavior all that much. It's all.
This was so true that in 10, 13,
Danish King spend fork bid invaded England and laid siege to London
as the reds initially mounted a successful resistance. But yeah, English Nobles,
nevertheless took the occasion to oust him from power.
They had been exasperated by his ineffective rule ends by the burden of the Dane
gals. So why not give to thrown to that Danish bloke as a read
Emma and their two children,
they fled to safety and Normandy where Edward was first exposed to Norman.
Cultural influence spent fork bid was crowned King of England on Christmas day,
10 13, but his reign was short-lived as he died just five weeks later.
That's the red, the unready.
He returns to the throne after he was recalled for Norman D by the West end,
the council of English nobleman at the red center had some ambassadors led to by
his son. Edward, I have been more than 11 or 12 years old,
but he acted as a consummate diplomat reassuring the Nobles that his father
would rule them fairly and tax them against further Danish.
Offensives the unready returns during lens of 10, 14,
and immediately actually per Patta face Knute, the son of spending. Yeah,
very aggressive intentions. The new King of the day,
it was led writing policies into much of Southern England through 10 50 Dean and
10, 16 plums, a ring and slaying with Gusto.
His army had grown stronger. Thanks to Alliance with Edrick powerful, uh,
of Mercia, which is roughly equivalent to today's Midlands.
Although I'll ask the red Lake ill in the town of caution and the marauding
Vikings were opposed by his son, Edmonds nicknames,
the iron site on April the 23rd, 10 sixteens, and George's day,
I thought red died as people shed a few tears. They,
as the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle records, this,
he ended his days having held his kingdom in much tribulation and difficulty,
as long as his life continued,
but were elected Edmund as the King and the Ironside continued the fight.
It appears that his half brother Edward was by his side. At this point,
our protagonist must have been about 14 years old and he had displayed religious
and diplomatic qualities so far,
but that didn't stop the young Prince from proving himself as a beast of a
warrior. According to a Scandinavian source,
during a battle with the Danes for the control of London,
Edward came within striking distance of King Knute.
He then delivered a formidable downward blow with his sword.
One of candidates leftenants thought,
or the tool shoved his King out of harm's way,
but the force of the blow was such that it smoked a Sunder,
the saddle and the horses back, Oh,
for a defeated Ashington in the County of Essex Edmonds agreed to an Alliance
with Knute. Under these terms, the deans would retain control of Mercia.
And as much of the North of England, while abdomen would rule over West six,
which corresponds to Southwestern England's from London to Cornwall in November
of the same year,
Edmund died of natural causes and declared himself King of the whole of England
supported by a large part of the wet end.
[Inaudible].
To ensure the stability of his throne Kony set of out,
getting rid of his potential rivals. First,
he ordered the killing of Edward younger brother of the late King Edmonds.
Then he exiled the two infant sons of Edmonds to Sweden arranging for them to be
assassinated. Fortunately, this didn't happen,
but the two princes would not return to England for decades.
The same fate could have before an Edward and his brother Alfred.
So they left the country for a second voluntary exile in Normandy.
While there Edward learns that's in July 10, 17,
his mother Emma had married Knute.
This was a blow capable of breaking a horse into had Emma of
Normandy married, a sworn enemy of their own family. The marriage was in fact,
an astute power move aimed at smoothing the transition from the old rule of the
Westech Saxons to the new reign.
Emma was also aware that her own children were too removed from the line of
succession and that she risked deportation or even assassination.
If she did not accept the offer to marry can moot. Lastly,
Emma took the occasions. You soften the otherwise harsh rule of Knute,
especially in the first years of his reign walking,
he traveled extensively back and forth between England and Denmark.
Emma acted as the de facto ruler of the country,
reducing when possible the heavy taxes imposed by her husbands.
She also reimbursed church property out of her own pocket after it was damaged
by the rowdy Danish armies. So all in all,
and the second marriage was less an act of betrayal than a calculated move to
protect herself into her adopted country. However,
distant teenage sons may have not understood this notion at the time Edward
spent his formative in Normandy,
gradually turning to the church and religion for comfort support and advice and
keeping with his origin story.
The Prince develops piety and devotion worthy of a Bishop.
Yet he maintains ambitions worthy of a King.
He vowed that he would return to England one day as its rifle ruler,
but succession was not an easier fab. First of all,
canoes already had a man M ought to take his place.
This was a son Harold Halford conceive from a previous yes,
marriage Edwards ambitions were further frustrated when he learns that Emma runs
Knute its size. Another son, half the canoes. As we say in England,
they had an a and a spare leaving very little chance for Edward to return to the
throne as dreams, Prince Hoff, canoed for succession.
I wonder then that Edward turns to his more distant Norman relatives for
familiar comfort and support port over the years,
Edward cemented his relationship with the Norman.
Aerostar bringing them to his cause that you normally himself. Robert,
the first attempt did an invasion of England in 10 34 with the goal of
attempting to restore Edward do his rightful position.
The expedition was thwarted by unfavorable winds and the whole project was
abandoned when Robert died the following year in November of 10 35,
another funeral took place on the other side of the channel King Knute had
died. His son,
Emma [inaudible] was declared King of Denmark while Harold Halford stood as
regions in England.
Now the fact that King Harold had no reason to show any loyalty to his dad's
second wife, Anna.
He could have gotten rid of her at any moments needed protection.
And it may be for this reason that she invited her two sons back to England from
Norman deep, shortly after that,
Alfred was quickly captured by an opportunistic Godwin of West 60,
wanted to ingratiate himself with half foot Godwin sleeve,
most of Alfred's and then handed them over to Herald.
The Anglo-Saxon Chronicle describes what followed as such a deed. More dreary,
none in this all land was done since Englishman gave place to hoards of Danish
race. Harold's men blinded poor Alfred with red hot pokers,
and then left him to die inside of him on a street.
Edward had to escape back to Normandy once again,
adding Godwin to his list of enemies without support from her sons.
Emma was eventually expelled by Harold and forced to live in Bruge modern day
belts. From there, she wants again, appeal to Edward Bay,
waiting for his help in securing the succession and Hopkins favor.
Understandably Edward refuse to provide anything help.
He was pious and religious and all of that,
but this was taking things just a bit too far.
In any case Emma's wishes came true even without help from Edward.
When Harold half died in 10 40 half,
the canoes was able to take the throne in England.
The following year heart's going.
It was proved to be a more magnanimous Monique than his father.
He did not excellent or assassinate potential threats to the throne. Actually,
he did the opposite upon him, his insistence,
he invited Edward back to England to designated emesis successor.
Suddenly Edward was just a few months away from the goal of a lifetime.
In fact, on June the eighth,
10 42 half can it died in a way befitting of such a turbulent
time. He died by poisoning alcohol poisoning to be exact.
In other words, he totally drank himself to death.
Even with Hoskin it's blessing,
Edward still needed the wet on the council of Nobles to support his Ascension.
This was not a given, but he did enjoy their support.
Thanks to the lobbying of the three most powerful Saxon Earl's Leah for ax
seaward, and a wafer. It Godwin Earl of Wessex. Yeah,
the same guy who played Lackey to Harold Halford and who had caused the gruesome
death of Edward's brother. Alfred, it may sound strange,
but Edward and Godwin did forge an uneasy Alliance born out of political
opportunism. And of course, thanks to the wetlands support.
Edward was crowned King of England on April the third, 10 43.
One of the first recorded actions taken by the new King took place on November
the 16th, 10 43,
Edward supported by Godwin and his retinue paid a surprise visit to his mother,
Emma in Winchester in a Swift action. Edward took revenge,
a bond DM mother, as I explained earlier,
her actions after the death of Ethel red may have been politically justifiable.
Angie had insisted that house candidates invited Edward back to England,
but on a personal level, it is understandable.
If Edward felt very little affection towards his mother became seized.
All of her Lamb's properties and jewels even had her evicted from her official
residence at Winchester castle.
And that I needed some nine years later in virtual poverty and obscurity.
After this incident,
Edward's reign was fairly stable as described by biographer William of
Malmesbury. There was no foreign war, always calm and peaceable,
both at home and abroad.
He conducted himself so mildly that he would not even utter a word of reproach
to the meanest person. Malmesbury clearly appreciated Edward's rule.
As he praised his domestic policies in the exaction of taxes,
he was sparing as the abominate, the insulins of collectors,
this good King abrogated bad laws with his and established good ones
and filled with joy, all that Britain over which she ruled. Nonetheless,
Edward had to deal with internal conflict, the same ELLs who,
which supported his claim soon grew suspicious of Edwards pro and leanings.
These were reflected in his administrative and ruling style. More visibly.
The Norman influence was evidence in the new Abby.
He ordered be built Westminster.
Rabih the first English church in the Norman Romanesque architectural style.
Edward knew that of the Earls of the West and the most powerful was Godwin.
He sold to prevent any conspiracy by becoming a relative of his in January 10
45, Edward married Godwin's daughter, Edith Godwin, may of 12,
his mustache at the thought of becoming grandfather to a future King excepts
Edward constantly torn between political power and religious pursuits made a vow
of chastity. Edwards' demeanor was increasingly pre-sliced.
He was popular among his subjects for his piety and devotion soon,
developing a reputation as a bit of a Holy man,
according to biographers God glorified King Edward with the gift of miracles,
Chronicle or spurts of Claire tells a story of how the King helped a blind man
from Lincoln did recover his sight.
Or how about another anonymous biographer who wrote about a young woman who was
plagued by a nasty infection of the throat in glands,
the disease worse than so much.
So that worms together with pus and blood came out of various holes.
One night the woman had a dream that she would be healed if the King washed her
face,
Edward heard about her and agreed to carry out the treatment hardly had she been
a quarter a week when all found us washed away,
the grace of God molded her with beauty.
The writer specifies that these prodigies left the English in orbit.
Also that Edward had been performing routinely similar miracles as a young man.
Normandy.
The Normans haven't quite left the story just yet,
which seems like a bit of a recurring theme,
but the life event with the confessor Edward's mother was Norman.
His upbringing was Norman. His most trusted advisors were Norman.
And sometime during his exile,
he had even allegedly designated a Norman air Jean Quilliam in 10 51,
Edward appointed a Norman.
Robert [inaudible] is Archbishop of Canterbury against the direct wishes of his
father-in-law Godwin.
Archbishop Robert was not too keen on Goldwin either as he reported that the air
was plotting to assassinate the King,
the relationship was reaching a bit of a breaking point.
Things went from bad to worse in September.
The town spoke of Dover attacked a retinue of a Norman visitor,
the counts of billowing in retaliation,
the King ordered Godwin's exact punishment on the town. Godwin refused.
He began raising an army with his eldest sons fan and Harold,
the rebel L marched against the King who was taken by surprise.
The English crown could raise a national militia, but it needed time.
Only the most powerful Nobels could rely on standing armies,
which they could mobilize in a short amount of time. In this case,
Edward was saved at the last moment by the C-word exams,
we are afraid that a powerful contingent against God when the kingdom was spared
a civil war though, as both parties, weren't really keen to find reasons well,
who could really blame them.
Edward and Godwin agreed on a different way to settle their disputes.
They would convene a meeting of the wit and in London by the end of 10 51,
at which the Earl of Wessex and his sons would then their grievances against the
King. Edward got wins that Godwin's fan and Harold's were coming to London.
All right.
But they were bringing along their army to the King now had more time to act.
And so he issued an order for the militia to be convened from all English lands.
Most of the nights in Godwin's service were more loyal to the King than do their
role. And so they abandoned the West six forces to join Edwards.
By the time Goldwin arrived in London, his forces had just melted away,
King Edward delivered the next blow by outlawing the Earl and his family.
In a matter of days that all left England perils and another brother had sought
refuge in Ireland, Godwin and his other sons exiled themselves to Flanders.
Next,
Edward confiscated all of Godwin's estates and riches before enacting the final
stages of his revenge play.
You may remember that Godwin was actually the King's father-in-law well,
Edward decided he couldn't trust his own wife Edith.
So he sent her away to a nunnery Edward's advantage against Godwin's family was
short-lived though without the metal.
Some of father-in-laws around Edward took the occasion to invite more Norman
advisors to court. This ill-advised decision irked,
some members of the West who turns their sympathies towards the exiled out of
West six in the summer of 10 52 Goldwind returns to England's landing in cans
with a powerful fleet. At the same time, his son, Harold,
a competent military leader, disembarked in Devin,
the two armies converged near sandwich.
And from there launched an attack towards London.
The Anglo Saxon Chronicle describes how on this occasion Edward's reaction was
slow and indecisive many Southern Lords and Knights that already signed with
Goldwind due to the antinomian sympathies as Godwin's army swelled and March to
London. It plundered, burned and looted without a restraint.
Many landowners went to King Edward to ask for help,
but when he failed to Mount a timely counter attack,
they were all too happy to switch sides. When Godwin and Harold reached London,
Edward's army and fleet were entirely surrounded by their enemies. Once again,
England was on the brink of a large-scale civil war. And once again,
it was averted at the last minute.
It's when officers are in both armies preferred to parlay, rather than a fight,
the truce was followed by another meeting of the West end in London,
which resulted in a humiliating defeat for Edward and the council Godwin and his
sons were cleared of all charges that had been laid against them.
Treason rebellion,
conspiracy to assassinate the King and to even Godwin's role in causing the
death of Alfred Edward pressed by the majority of the Nobles had to comply the
wits and also demanded for Archbishop Robert to be proclaimed and outlawed
alongside other Norman advantages.
Godwin died the following year in quite a dramatic fashion.
Evidently he choked on a piece of breads after swearing to the King.
Let's go to who knows all things be. My judge may this crust of bread,
which I hold in my hands,
pass through my throat and leave me unharmed to show that I was innocent of your
brother's death, just the Shaun and Freud of his death go to it.
And his family had imagined victorious from that deal with Edward moreover,
the Norman influence had been removed from course, if do Quilliam of Norman's.
He wanted to set on the English throne, Hey, I have to earn their right by four
Edward ends it his sixth decade. It became clear that he would die childless.
So who would succeed him?
We already know that he would have appointed William of Normandy as his heir on
a previous occasion, but this choice was not palatable to the Whitman,
the council of Nobles pressed for another alternative, you know,
the children of Edmond Ironsides Xcel to Sweden. Well,
the eldest who was also called Edward was still alive and kicking and hungry in
10 56, the King decided to have him brought back to England.
He entrusted this difficult task to his old enemy. Harold's son of Godwin.
Now Harold Godwinson after the death of Godwin,
Edward Hood learns to appreciate Harold's qualities. I like his father.
Harold had proven to be loyal to the King and he was also a successful military
leader. He had proven his skill by beating several victorious campaigns against
rebellious Welch lead up Harold succeeded on his mission returning with Prince
Edward in the summer of 10 57. But on August the 31st,
the Prince died of unknown causes. Had he been poisoned by Harold? Well,
according to pro Norman sources. Oh yes. More realistically though.
Probably not. If that was Harold's intention,
why not just kill the Prince during the long journey back from hungry,
it just doesn't make sense. Prince Edward died leaving a young son behind Edgar,
a filling or thrown worthy.
He was considered by part of the wits end as another possible candidate to the
throne. Despite his young age,
a larger faction in the meanwhile started to consider Harold as a more palatable
success.
He was an effective military leader brother-in-law to the King and ruler of the
most powerful of the English Adams.
Harold star continued to rise in the early 10 sixties.
Edward gradually withdrew from government matters,
preferring to dedicate his time to prayer religious studies and the completion
of Westminster Abbey.
The King preferred to dedicate his most serious matters to Harold and other
members of his family in 10 63, Harold's younger brother toast, toasted quelled,
a rebellion in Northumbria,
following which the two brothers crushed once of rural Prince egg in North Wales
ever more dependent on Harold in 10 64,
Edward sent him on a diplomatic mission to Normandy.
During which time he met Duke William.
What happens in the meeting is disputed according to pro Norman salsas,
the aim of Harold's emission was to confirm to William that he was the
designated successor to the English throne. According to Prozacs and accounts,
Harold was there to negotiate and aligns with the Normans and the succession was
not even discussed. The already puzzling situation was made even more confusing,
biking, Edward himself at the end of 10 65,
the King fell ill and there was nothing that could be done as he lay on his
death bed. During the finest calendar week of the new year,
he called for Harold and pledged the crown to him as a reward for his
services or at least rats Harold's Vashon King,
Harold Godwinson rushed to,
to have himself declared King the very same day of Edward's death.
January the fifth, 10 66
Harold's position was a little-bit secure Edgar.
The Aisling may not have been a credible contender,
but William of Normandy was a fearsome rival. If that wasn't enough,
there was a fourth claimant to the throne, Norwegian King, Harold Hardrada.
Now I'm not going to go into details of what happens next.
For those you can set for our biographics video on William, the conqueror,
I will instead consider King Edward's legacy.
His record as a successful leader is criticized by some historians.
His reign was largely peaceful. Sure,
but he could have sped the country much inviting hands.
He acted more decisively when dealing with Godwin has predilection for Norman
customs and his own Norman heritage was perceived positively by Pronamel and
Chronicles.
FRC could be considered the first of the Norman Kings rather than the last of
the Saxons. However,
his unchecked bias towards advisers and bishops from that land eventually caused
discontent amongst SACS and nobleman over time memories of his piety and stories
of his miracles took over his more earthly deeds and 1163,
almost a century after his death.
Edward was formally proclaimed to saints and styled. The confessor.
This title indicates the scene to suffers for his faith,
but is one step short of martyrdom in 1269 Edward's bones were laid in
Westminster, Abbey here's Abbey,
which back then was the most sumptuous shrine in the Western world.
Edward was England's patron Saint until 1348 when he was replaced by Saint
George. His culture remained alive for centuries though.
And sick of pilgrims would sleep by his shrine in the hope of being cured.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did smash that like button below,
don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].